another video from a couple days ago
that I meant to get to fortunately we
have time today
Joe Biden
chewed on a child
and if you're if you're not
if you're not watching this
if you're not watching if you're just
hearing it I don't know how I can
describe it to you it's not I can't
overstate how weird this is
he leans in and it's not just a little
nuzzling with the child I actually think
that's kind of cute I know people say
that everything Joe Biden does is really
creepy and some of the things he does
but I don't know playing around making
goofy faces at a child I think that's
kind of cute but he leans in and just
starts
chewing on the child
and then he leans in and makes a goofy
face and then
he smells her hair again
he does the hair smell thing that's got
him in so much political trouble
and my takeaway from this is not as some
more
eccentric or energetic right-wingers
might say that he's a pedophile or
something like that my takeaway here is
the guy is in cognitive decline because
even if his mastication on the child and
the hair smelling is totally innocent
it's a huge political loser for him and
he is constantly criticized for it and
it's completely unnecessary and yet he
keeps doing it and why does he do it I
assume it's because he is obviously in
the throes of cognitive decline and the
thing that we haven't talked about too
much on the right we've all been making
fun of how Joe Biden you know is a
couple fries short of a Happy Meal you
know but Joe Biden is uh you know is not
the sharpest tool in the shed and seems
to be getting worse
if you've ever experienced cognitive
decline with a loved one a family member
someone like that you you know it's not
it's not just a gradual thing
starts out kind of slow and then it gets
dramatically worse
cognitive decline
at a certain age
really accelerates
and we've seen it really accelerate with
Biden and just think even though they
keep Biden broadly out of the public
site even though he doesn't give a lot
of speeches or rallies or campaign or
anything like that
this guy has a lot of pressure on him he
does have to be in public a considerable
amount
that pressure is on the one hand might
keep him a little bit with his wits
about him because at least his mind will
be stimulated but that's a lot of
pressure that's a lot of stress at that
age
Biden Biden could decline rapidly we
keep saying on the Republican side it
was a long way until the election right
that cuts both ways it's a long way
until the election if this is where we
are with Joe Biden now if we've seen
this kind of a decline from 2020 to 2023
is this guy going to be able to walk
around the campaign Trail in 2024 or is
Gavin Newsom going to be waiting in
the wings right now go to geniusell.com
our friends over at genucel sold out of
their Dark Spot Corrector and our
listeners have been begging for a
restock begging on their hands and knees
well I've got great news just in time
for the summer
it's back geniusell's famous Dark Spot
Corrector has not won but three Cutting
Edge ingredients and goes to work fast
to Target sunspots dark spots liver
spots and even old discoloration both on
your face and your hands you can now
enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
geniusell's most popular package also
features their summer Essentials such as
the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed how quickly you will
see results or 100 of your money goes
back guaranteed go to genucel.com
Knowles right now
get your dark spot corrector in the
geniusell most popular package that is
geniusell.com Knowles right now save
over seventy seven zero percent off
Junior cell's most popular package all
orders will include a mystery luxury
gift while supplies last geniusell.com
Knowles Maisy hirono
one of the
more frequently mocked members of the
United States Senate
Macy is a Democrat senator
she is insisting that if the Supreme
Court
does not adopt the code of ethics that
she wants it to adopt
then she and her fellow senators are
going to force one on the Supreme Court
first of all let's understand that the
United States Supreme Court does not
have a code of ethic the kind of code of
ethics that applies to all other federal
judges so the highest court in the land
should set a standard should set the
highest standard they do not so this is
a bill that would do that and what what
will it do it will establish a procedure
for investigating ethical violations
it'll make much clearer recusal
requirements and the third is to give
the court time to adopt the code of
ethics and if they do not then one will
be
provided to them
Senator how exactly do you plan to then
enforce those guidelines
some of the guidelines will be done
through the a commission that is
established by the judicial conference
and so that there are judicial
conference procedures for the
investigating these kinds of things
good on the CNN guy good on the CNN guy
for asking the obvious question here
What Maisie hirono is suggesting sounds
kind of nice if you don't know anything
about politics and haven't thought about
this issue for more than two seconds
because it's it's crazy that the Supreme
Court doesn't have a code of ethics now
first of all the Supreme Court obviously
has
quite a code of ethics it's not written
down on a sheet of paper necessarily but
the Supreme Court has all sorts of
traditions and ethical standards that it
abides by and they're very very high
but it doesn't have a written down
formal code of ethics that's true
why might that be
because it's the highest court in the
land and the the CNN guy raises this
question he says well
who's going to hold them accountable to
the code of ethics and Maisie hirono's
answer is very dangerous here and this
whole Movement by the Senate Democrats
to hold the Supreme Court to a code of
ethics that is just jargony euphemistic
gobbledygook to to allow for a senate
takeover of the Supreme Court to allow
for the Takeover of one branch of
government by another branch of
government because her answer is who's
going to hold them to it we will
we are going to decide what cases the
judges are allowed to operate the the
judges are allowed to participate in
and when we say that what do we mean we
mean we're going to make Clarence Thomas
recuse himself we're going to make Amy
Barrett recuse herself we're going to
make the leader we're going to make the
conservatives recuse themselves and
we're going to hold them accountable
that's not how the Constitution works
that's not how the branches of
government work this is
something that the Senate has no right
to do and if the Senate were able to
steal this kind of a power it would be
I I say without exaggeration probably
the biggest threat to our system of
government in at least half a century
maybe more man what a great clip that
was if you want more of those clips and
episodes and yes or no game and two and
a half hour interviews with horn hat
guys and all of it you got to ring the
bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time